the daughter of palestine
shireen abu aklay's body was taken
through ramallah where thousands
gathered to pay their respects
her remains then taken to a state
service where the palestinian president
honored her
he vowed to seek justice at the
international criminal court
today we are here to pay our respect to
shireen abu akhla the martyr of
palestine the martyr of jerusalem and
the martyr of free speech and the free
world
a symbol of the palestinian women a
symbol of the palestinian journalists
shireen has sacrificed her life to
defend its course and the cause of the
palestinian people
sharing worked for al jazeera and was
widely known for reporting on the
israel-palestine conflict for more than
two decades
everyone standing here has his own story
with syrian
as friends we experienced with her this
amazing person pure soul
and
innocent
professional journalist we always waited
for shireen to tell us the story we're
losing today a great storyteller
while covering a raid by israeli forces
in the occupied west bank on wednesday
she was shot in the head
and killed instantly
her colleague seen on the right ishatha
hanesha she says the attack on her team
was intended to kill
the occupation forces have led us to
reach that point where they fired on us
i want to tell her that i'm sorry i
couldn't protect you when we were under
fire i failed to save you
israel's government initially said
palestinian fighters were to blame
but that was disputed by witnesses
journalists and rights groups
this is the moment where there's going
to be the most outpouring of outrage and
grief about the killing of shireen so if
they can cast doubt if they can muddy
waters around the death of shireen by
possibly getting newspapers in the
international sphere to suggest that she
was killed by a palestinian they have
been successful
israel says it will investigate
shireen's killing and offered to do it
in conjunction with palestinian
officials the palestinian president said
he would not cooperate with israel
we refused any joint investigation
committee with israeli authorities
because they have committed such a crime
we don't trust them and will go
immediately to the international
criminal court in order to fight the
perpetrators and criminals
al jazeera media network has described
the 51 year old's death as blatant
murder shireen abu aklay was born in
jerusalem and her body has now been
taken to a hospital there on friday
there will be a funeral service in bait
hanina the same neighborhood she grew up
in
leah harding al jazeera